let you guys in on some internal stuff
when we were originally trying to book
their accommodation for the night
the hotel uh wouldn't let us do it we
don't know exactly what happened you
said it's for Kanye West why not just
say like uh you have to do credit card
authorization so when you book a hotel
this is the most annoying thing about
traveling anybody who travels for work
knows exactly what this is your company
will book your hotel and you'll shop and
they'll say and you have a credit card
on file and you're like my company
booked it with the company card
place it sucks right yes and so what we
have to do is we have to call in and
confirm our card details for the room
and as soon as we said who would be
checking like when you when you're when
you're booking a room you got to put
their name on it how else do they show
up and give you the name and then then
they're just like we'll get back to you
and put us on hold and then it was like
an hour later of like hold on we're
talking to the manager and then we're
like okay this is not working we're just
sitting on the phone so we canceled it
we got an Airbnb